a journalist and the author of the
confidence game why we fall for it every
time Maria konnikova okay so as someone
who wrote a book called the confidence
game we fall for it every time what did
you think when you saw Donald Trump
standing there in front of a table full
of his products to me that screamed cut
there a picture it screamed the
confidence man you know I saw him and I
thought I'm a psychic right because I
clearly predicted that this was going to
happen I mean the moment that they
analyzed what his products actually were
they found out that they weren't his
product not his product absolutely was
blatantly lying and the hallmark of a
second over well say see there you go
Freudian slip the hallmark of a
psychopath but also the harm of hallmark
of a con artist is someone who deceives
you for their own ends so they're trying
to convince you to support them to vote
for them in this particular case
um and they're doing it by just by
tactics that aren't actually it is this
I mean am I reading too much into this
but standing there in front of a table
full of steaks now I don't eat steak but
like most people love steak I thought
this was like subliminal advertising
kind of stuff like people looking at
that and going Trump steak if I vote
Trump I'll eat steak I mean they look
juicy you know steaks yeah go ahead
people yeah hmm you know what think of
the voters he's trying to appeal to so
he's actually going for that who would
like to eat steak you can't afford it
people who want to eat stay
great let the meat steak watch yeah it's
true and and I think that we see him
trying to get the popular vote it's the
same appeal that he makes all the time
that he is honest he's a man of the
people he's telling everyone exactly
what they want to hear and he doesn't
actually say anything so that's that's
what confidence are so he's so he's he's
a con man but he is a good one he's a
very good contract that's why they're
called con artists right mm-hmm DRD to
do and you make the point that you know
everyone is saying that Donald Trump is
good hijack the party but a con man
doesn't take anything from a bridge yeah
you give it to him willingly yes we give
them our confidence right origin of the
term confidence game was a man who stole
watches but he never actually stole them
he went up to people on the streets and
said have you confidence in me to lend
me your watch until tomorrow
oh and people gave them his watch
because they gave them they gave him
their confidence and that's exactly what
Trump is doing to the party he isn't
asking anyone for anything people are
willingly giving their trust the more I
read about this Trump University the
more it sounds like Scientology it does
people
people paying great sums of money to
find out a secret that isn't really a
secret and people being coerced to keep
giving good ratings
we have Scientology where you also have
some of the same course of tactics where
people basically get brainwashed into
into saying that Scientology is
wonderful trumps universities 98%
approval ratings I mean when we read
about true they really do have that high
approval rate
absolutely absolutely every single
person stands behind that rating so they
have people watching them and calling
them we read stories of people who say
that they've been called every single
day to change their rating and finally
say fine I'm good I'll change my rating
to 200% no you called him a psychopath
what first it is a psyche we all throw
that term around I'd be hard-pressed to
define it right now what is a psychopath
well there's actually a checklist here's
psychopathy check a checklist well I
know you have a checklist for narcissist
have personality have lots of chocolate
is that it different than a psychopath
nor it is but they actually both both of
those traits yeah there's a lot of
overlap there cuz here are some of your
narcissistic personality disorder
exaggerated sense of self-importance I
don't see that Donald no need for
excessive admiration again coming up
empty sense of entitlement where are you
getting this from
lacking empathy ha come on believing
others to be envious of him arrogant
haughty contemptuous behavior or
attitude so yeah yeah it sounds like he
might be on the edge of that I don't
think so I don't think so I don't think
it applies but a lot of these actually
overlap with with psychopathy like the
lack of empathy like the arrogance of
burndown of other people you don't so he
does this very funny thing where to his
voters he says really wonderful things
to their face and then behind their back
he says terrible things about the same
groups because he had makes the same
statement but opposite ways depending on
who he's talking to and so you end up
seeing these two sides of him where the
truth is a really fun jables thing and
there's no such thing as absolute truth
the truth is just what's true in the
moment to him well and that's both a
narcissist and a psychopath and those
are two of the dark triad of traits
the third is Machiavellianism right yes
okay and I don't want to
make you psycho analyze someone you
never met too much but last week before
they had the nice debate this week they
had the nasty debate and they were
talking about their penis size they were
it seems like he also is a prime
candidate for micro penis
you know no I mean somebody as always
I'm the best I'm the biggest I got the
greatest I mean isn't that obviously
someone who does have a scruffy
well I'm sure that dr. Freud would have
something to say I'm sure there's a
Napoleonic complex equivalent she don't
answer the question and we'll never know
I mean I wrote an editorial I wish I'd
known about your book about Trump called
the confidence man had about two months
ago but I do thought he is a very
skillful demagogue and he's dangerous
for that reason honestly and we all make
fun of him and I myself thought he can't
sustain this he'll fade it can't
possibly work but it has what more than
that I would have thought I feel like
what's so dangerous about him is that we
now have seen him for so many months and
gotten so used to all this behavior the
incredibly ridiculous bragging and the
insulting of everyone who looks at him
the wrong way
that it's so baked in the cake now that
he's alone that he could almost no
there's nothing he can do that shocks us
anymore or people don't go oh well
that's Donald Trump for you